man said i'm done
he said i'm done
i don't need she tried to walk out the
door she dragged her back and she said
please please don't that he said get off
me i'm i'm done
you're you're nuts fam
you're [ __ ] crazy
what are you even on about
[Music]
what's up guys what it do people what it
is what's up
got you
in the goddamn hey what it is
what's up what's up
oh
yo people monday fun day you know the
drills you know the vibes um second best
podcast in the world we're coming to you
again live with another banger
um what else can we say man um
it's what we're in march now you guys
have had two months to step your [ __ ]
up step your game up
get going with the new year's
resolutions like i hope your mind are
doing well hope you're kind of doing
healthy you know i hope you guys have
been chirps and things in the comments
because that's what we're about that is
what as jimmy's always saying meaning
that breeding ground you know
you know the uniform white robes
easies
all white attire with the black skin
can be anyway with the black saiyan why
is that that that moccasina
glaze
you know flat white
[Music]
never call yourself a flat white again
flat white
um
that's hilarious
a flat one
but yeah guys you already know what to
do we're going to ask you to pause this
episode right quick okay just pause it
real quick head on over to patreon.com
forward slash shits and giggs
patreon.com for shits and gigs and what
you're going to get yourself there guys
is two years
to two years years worth of backlog
content every patreon episode we've ever
shot
is on there over on patreon every single
thursday guys you're gonna check in with
us you're gonna get yourself a bonus
episode
um every month you're going to chat to
us on zoom calls you're going to get
first dibs on all of your
recommendations all your fan requests or
your mi archives or your x whatever it
is
um you're going to get 30 off all of
merch
um and guys you're going to be part of a
very select
um it's like a few selections like few
set group and like like-minded
individuals about yourself um if you
think the comments are chirps and over
here come on man they're chirps in there
[Laughter]
legs get spread
but anyway um
so guys head on over patreon.com four
size shits and gigs it's gonna cost you
a young three pound a month 10p a day
run the p you already know what it is
and um
also guys if you are watching this on
youtube we would very much appreciate it
if again you'd hit the comments chirp
yourself a ting uh two fingers of death
on the notification bell like and
subscribe if you are hearing this the
soul mellow voices of your boy jay money
and fire lord wakes please
also do us a favor
um give us a rate and leave a review it
means the world to us it does so much
for our growth spreading the word
getting the breeding grounds um funding
the log cabin in the forest you already
know it is yeezys and robes are not
cheap they're not cheap and the gate
we're going to put around the community
as well as not yeah it's going to be a
gated community and none of these things
come for free so yeah if you could
really really help us out and uh leave a
review we'd very much appreciate it
um
and on top of that guys last but not
least you may notice
oh your boys are wearing similar gums
today well they're wearing similar
hoodies it looks the same but man ain't
seen that before i was on the website
yesterday i didn't see that i didn't see
that
and there's again oh
i can't my eye vision's not that good
you know it looks like i
lying about
your boys stay clean always but maybe
you can't read it yeah
it says what the ick oh no it happened
oh snap it actually hasn't actually
happened boys have ich merch out now
sorry not sorry
[Laughter]
yo
your boys have ick much out now saw's
not saw bad highly requested
merch limited edition limited keyword
limited edition was it this week only
this week only guys limited edition guys
this week only what the ich merch
launches today today
today launch is today next monday is off
the website in the dare
off the website in seven full days
you've got a week
so you better start yeah
so guys head on over to um
wherever we sell our merch
the links in the bio links in the bio
man the links in the box links in the
bio links head on over grab as much as
you can yeah man because there's stock
but there's a time limit yeah yeah so
head on over um we've got teas we've got
hoodies we've got sweatshirts you've got
whatever you want head on over for get
the what the egg merch is only for this
week guys so if you don't get it this
week
so sauce not sauce sorry if you're
watching this episode in four weeks time
because you're new to the party or maybe
you were on holiday
sorry there's
nothing we can do about that i'm afraid
you're gonna have to run a young nft
thing
and resale thing you're gonna have to
hit up the comments on the resale thing
yeah that's nothing to do with that has
nothing to do with us yeah so guys grab
as much as you can yeah man because yeah
man are going to look back on this
episode in a few weeks time and be vex
about it because the ick boys have ich
merch now no one else is doing this
so guys run on over link's in the
description get your merch today okay um
and and enjoy it that's all i can say
really um
but without any further ado we actually
have we haven't had one of these in a
while we've got a little unboxing yeah
so unboxing the homie fern her details
will be in the description as well she's
hooked us up with quite a bit of artwork
and she's come through again i've had
this in my yard for a few weeks now um
so i decided to bring it to the stew to
do an unboxing live and direct for you
man
so yeah oh
it's a big gun guys it's a big she said
it comes with a lickle
let's see what the what what this treat
is first performer it's probably sweet
she knows me yeah she knows we've got a
little sweet tooth in it yeah my tooth
is my teeth are teething
a yankee candle
and sign to stick up the ting with oh my
god my girl and what's this
a little face ting say less that's just
yours say less did i get one
it says food
oh no yeah because you ordered it
specifically i wasn't involved in this i
forgot
wow she she does well she does do he
does well i said it says foo here bruh
yeah
that's disrespectful
on her part of my part your part my bad
guys that's her phone i'm not bad my bad
that bad let me unbox this nice and
nice and neatly i don't want to mess it
up guys
it's been a minute since we've done
ladies yeah it has actually let me get
this out the way hold on
[Music]
guys even the packaging is immense
doesn't matter she pays attention man
she does pay attention pay attention to
she yeah attention to details doesn't
mess about it's one of her strengths
like i said guys um her
app and everything will be in the
description so please check her out if
she's interested
artiste if you are interested in any
form of artwork
oh wow
wow
um yeah so this is
incredible guys let me take this bubble
wrap off so you might can see in its
flesh
mod
mod mod mod
i'm struggling i don't know how many
nick are living from unboxing videos
because this is taking a time
i need the box cut already next yeah
next time boxcar are ready sorry people
it looks sick that actually looks better
in person than it did in the picture
all right let me see the thing as well
right guys you ready to see it
wow that looks sick that's incredible
that looks actually much better in
person than it did in the picture
incredible not to say it didn't look
good in the picture but yeah
that's wild
so guys it is a
it's a backdrop of our faces
backdrop of our faces
with
the back print of our summer sng match
yeah so all the slogans always find the
funny
we got the
one's gotta go run the p one's gotta go
tequila sip sip yeah titties and tan
manny on the map always gang gang dangly
dang
yo
the trucker dave trucker dave wow run
the peter sng the works yeah this is
heavy guys
phone the creator join the creator her
deets are in the description and these
will be coming along the screen now as
well
hit her up man she's gonna
she's gonna look after you and this is
definitely going up on the wall of fame
so yeah thank you thank you for your
personal shout out
gang gang sexy
it's okay that only i got a gift i mean
i know you ordered it i mean
yeah i wanted it for the stew you know i
know you did i don't know what to do
you did surprise me i did i wanted you
to surprise me because when she posted
it on her instagram i was like what a
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah the [ __ ] is
that
the thing is the thing is like
obviously she likes to promote her stuff
but i didn't want to tell her don't post
it because i'm going to do an unboxing
but obviously it's hurting herself yeah
but um again fun love appreciate it
that's amazing
like i said everyone guys if you if you
want some artwork like that holler
she'll look after you
okay gang um so we've got a little
segment to start off with early segments
early segment let's let's laugh from the
jump guys so um the other week i asked
you guys on the instagram what's the
moment you realized your partner was
crazy obviously we were going back and
forth because you men were giving me
content after content after content yeah
but i had to take some down cut it was
too many for me to reply to so you know
here we are we're going to do some for
the fandom now
so again the moment you realized your
partner was crazy
man said called my whole family to make
sure where i was so to make sure i said
where i was
whilst he was out cheating
[Laughter]
man didn't want to get caught fam he
didn't want to get caught he was a yard
he was cheating in the marital bed
family called the whole family to make
sure i don't know who he while he was
out cheating so i'm assuming maybe you
go
to make sure where i said i was where i
said i was yes
so he could cheat he could cheat in
peace
he didn't have to be looking through the
yeah yeah
yeah
bro if he says any car pull up he's
no he actually had to make sure fair
play fair play i think um speaking of
that i think men who cheat domestically
i reckon ring doorbells are a lifesaver
oh with the face ting yeah as well
because they give you a lot and a lot
have you ever been in a house with a
ring doorbell no they give it tells you
when there's someone even approaching
the door oh mad mad man it was a
movement near the front door
movement
i would dismantle the whole thing
it says there's movement by the front
door
usually get a [ __ ] out yeah
dead all of that dead all of that safe
that's jokes
the moment you realize your partner was
crazy drank sparkling water as a
hangover cure
[Laughter]
nah
nah
bro
sparkling water that's who wants static
in their mouth like that bro
sparkling water in pit period period is
for devil spawns
sons of lucifer drinks sparkling
sparkling water tastes like [ __ ] it
literally tastes like static yeah
literally like a like like a broken
television is what the sparkling was it
yeah it just
paranormal activity is what the ring is
the ring
the ring
it's just not on what's the point what
is the point of it yeah all right next
one
started making animal noises during sex
i left
swear down what kind of you need to be
specific with that
they didn't specify it could have been a
horse thing it could have been a dog
thing it could have been a sheep thing i
don't know all of them are weird yeah i
don't know
broke up but still living together
woke up one morning around four-ish to
him watching me sleep
oh yeah that's kind of oh and they're
broken up
separate routine
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
came in the next room and just watched
her sleep crazy crazy too fair that
wasn't gender-specific was it uh not in
this context but i obviously knew who
sent it yeah
a guy watched a girl sleeping yes of
course i thought pisses me off of course
i know yeah without without even
any whatever without a shadow of a doubt
bro
it has to be a guy
guys are the craziest man it pisses me
off
when i had to hide in her sister's
wardrobe
for what
she was lying about sam yeah she didn't
want she was lying about son she didn't
want anyone to find out yeah yeah i
don't want anyone to find out come this
one is west brother when he gets out the
shower and licks the condensation off
the mirror
i'm did that made me dizzy
[Laughter]
licks the
condensation that's so specific it has
to be true has to be true
and i would love to know
what conversation went down the first
time she caught him
because
that's
like why are you thirsty i don't
understand are you trying to just see
where you just yeah what are you into my
job that's different brother it is
different that's different brother
there's a sink in the way so you have to
tiptoe over the sink
just to get a lick on the window what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
yo
yo
[Laughter]
keeping track of my periods to know if
i'm actually on or if i'm cheating and
avoiding having sex with him ah
that's intricate
that's intricate brother so she can't
use the um my period excuse me
keeping track of them you know wrong
maybe 28.
wow so she could blow babes i'd love to
but i'm i'm just starting my period a
man looks like he's watching opens the
canopy
glasses
i don't think you are yes no you're not
ourselves says you are our survey pull
down your drawers
survey says you're not pull down your
drawers
let me see
run me the strings
that's what i want to say run me the
string quick let me see it let me see
nah oh my goodness
when he told me to [ __ ] his ass with my
big toe
dearie me
i mean i don't think that's not fair to
say crazy we don't do the kink shaming
on this show yeah fair king show yeah
fair fair
but when you hear it for the first time
oh yeah if not if we're in a
relationship yeah and then you
sporadically say [ __ ] my ass with your
specifically big toe
specifically
yeah that can come across as a bit a bit
loopy a little bit loopy but as we said
we don't keep you don't kick shame
it's um it's just a bit out of our field
of expertise yeah it's out of the remit
yeah but that's needless to say that's
that could be standard procedure it's
never here nor their mind yeah we don't
judge get your toe in it get your toe
yeah also yeah just [ __ ] his ass in it
when he suggested i up my antidepressant
dota
when he suggested i up my antidepressant
dosage when i caught him cheating
a savage brother
that is savage brother
oh
my gosh you're gonna need serotonin to
get through you're gonna need more of it
so up it she walked in on him clapping
cheeks i said up the dosage the dosage
because you're going to need it
we know you're not leaving me yeah we
know you're not leaving me so just up
the dosage we can get on with it because
i'm trying to live my life
and i don't want to hear it
fam
he gets in the tub then fills it with
water
man gets in a tub naked stalkers
dry tub dry top and then fills it with
water you're
a maniac brother you're a maniac brother
who does that
nah
brother nah
brother go go go go go shot in my front
yard and blamed it on my disabled sister
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they might be lying to me but this is
what they read this is what they wrote
down for man
this is what they replied he's trying to
get her in in
in in like a cared home or something you
know he wants her out yeah long story
short he wants her out he's not trying
to deal with that when he's trying to
clap
[ __ ] god
no bro
bro no listen
oh the sisters none the wiser
[Laughter]
what a piece of [ __ ] oh brother what a
piece of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's
top five funniest things you've ever
said
that's top five funniest things i've
ever heard on this show
blamed it on my disabled sister
that's
[Laughter]
that's the new levels of love it says
listen oh [ __ ] i can't speak i can't
think i can't do anything
that's too funny bro [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me that's hilarious
right
let me get through a couple more yeah
come on
he said
when i get really excited it feels like
my teeth are about to fall out
what does that even mean
what
when i get poked when i get really
excited it feels like my teeth are about
to fall out
that makes no sense to me it doesn't
make any sense that makes no sense to me
brother
[Laughter]
go on when he pretended to cry real
tears in the fetal position because i
wouldn't let him bum me
she used to bark like dmx when we had
sex
[Laughter]
listen
[Laughter]
wow i didn't pick up his call one time
and he said that's why your mom has no
hair
fun that's making my back hurt doesn't
make him a bad backer
i'm not joking that's squeezing my abs
so much it's making my back up
oh
[ __ ] that that's why your mum has no
hair
wow
yo why doesn't her mum have hair though
that's true
oh [ __ ] when she chased me around the
house with a spider in her hands
that's that's not even funny that's a
torment that's taught that's torture
yeah that she's actually crazy
because the thing is i'll rock you in
your nose and it's just it's not my
fault i'm going pen i know it's not my
fault it's just retaliation yeah at this
point yeah it's quick reaction yeah
don't rent don't chase me with a [ __ ]
spider you're an [ __ ]
because even if you don't have a fear of
spiders you have to run away you have to
because that's not normal that's just
not normal because i'm not having
someone dash a spider on me it's not
happening i'd love to threaten you with
a spider
i would love to threaten you with a
spider the same way i'd love to lock you
in a room with birds yeah it ranks yeah
yeah i would love to catch a spider in a
cup a fat one and [ __ ] just flinch at
you consistently
your reaction would be yeah whilst i'm
[ __ ] like cagey yeah
just
i'd scream james i know you would
he would threat
how much do you want because i'm tired
of this i already know you're
threatening me oh [ __ ] it um
let's crack on man yeah sorry oh
that was too funny jesus christ that was
too funny
that's one of the best segments we've
done
thank you guys yeah thanks guys thank
you guys that was [ __ ] hilarious i've
broken sweat for that um
wow
cool wow right let me get breath i've
got something to say yeah hit me hit me
hit me where is my water
it's giving me a headache this early on
in an episode
i didn't need a headache like that
wow
jesus christ i'm hot man
[ __ ] me
oh right before we continue guys again
what the ich merch
this week only
link in the description limited seven
days grab as much as you can yeah man
run us the p
[ __ ] my head hurts now
oh [ __ ] i don't know whose idea was it
was to do it that early on
it was like all right killing me if you
had perfect i hope you guys laughed so
much we did [ __ ] that was funny um i
said where my dogs are
right
that's what you're hearing listen
yo
these men are funny cuz bro these men
are funny you the public are just the
funniest people literally the best
comedians our country our world has to
offer are just the general public
you men are just comedians
okay guys we're going to take a quick
break from the episode to share some
love on our boys over at manscape
um so now guys spring has sprung
spring has sprung i'm sprung
um and it's time to get down to some
spring cleaning okay so our friends at
manscape have the best
tools for said spring cleaning
in your pants standard that's the the
most important type of spring cleaning
the spring cleaning downstairs hundred
percent you gotta take everyone takes
care of upstairs you gotta take care of
downstairs
then basements to be fair you just need
to sometimes yeah every couple whatever
every couple of months every couple
weeks whatever you need to get down in
the basement and clean up clean up look
after it make space yeah
come on man you know and uh trust me
guys your confidence will be
blooming like the flowers this upcoming
spring come on say less uh so it's time
to clean out that winter bush and join
the other four million men
we're responsible for half of that we've
discussed this before the four million
men who trust manscaped as well as
ourselves um so what you need to do is
rush on over
um
to manscape.com
the code is sng sierra november golf
manscape.com sng you're gonna patent
yourself 20 off and free shipping one
more time for the people in the back
manscaped.com
the code is sng sierra november golf say
less twenty percent off free shipping
thank you very much let's get back to
the episode
it's too funny
um thank you for that bro
i've got a television show
dang
i've got a show for you skank you know i
love so many people have watched it and
told me to watch i was never going to
watch it before the other day [ __ ] it
i'm gonna watch say less love is blind
season two i'm hearing about it because
i've seen love is blind season one and
i've seen love is blind
like maybe a few episodes of the brazil
one because bella watched it as well so
i was watching it yeah
but why is season two bump banging like
that love is blind season two is wavy
the only the only context i know is one
brother like my man that's playing the
guitar ukulele or something oh you play
soccer yeah you play soccer salvador
okay yeah really
okay let me tell you before we start let
me tell you about salvador so he
patterned the body yeah he patterned the
baddest girl in the whole show okay and
he's a wet wipe
okay but
he knows how he knows how and when to be
a [ __ ] okay in the terms of like that
when he did this ukulele thing it was
wet but he just did it at the perfect
time for her okay
where she was already under his neck
like she was already caught yeah yeah
yeah yeah she pushed her over to the
edge yeah yeah tinder swindler type yeah
yeah yeah because he did this one thing
right so he's uh
latino okay and then yeah that he was
talking to that he was vibing with her
name's um
oh [ __ ] how i forgot mal mallory
um and she's half latina okay so she
doesn't speak that much spanish but
he'll throw in little bits of spanish
that she does understand
now and again
so um
obviously in spanish uh the word donde
means where yeah fam they would talk
about tattoos they were getting
yeah what was it three years two years
of spanish
two and a half two and a half years
yeah yeah yeah yeah donde so one time
fam they were talking and that the [ __ ]
was getting a bit heated so actually let
me give a premise
anyone who'd have no idea what level i
know i know about the show you know what
it is of course so love is blind you can
find it on netflix is a show where the
premise is
people are too obsessed with looks and
they're not building true connections
with people they're just going a
physical attraction so you're basically
stuck in a room
separated by a wall
for your your your partner or whatever
and you go on basically these blind
dates where there's like 12 men or 12
women or something like that um
and you have the opportunity to have
dates with these people and get to know
them purely on an emotional level and a
personality level and you never know
what they look like until
you're actually engaged yeah yeah until
you propose to them and you're willing
to be with them for the rest of your
life that's when you get to see what
they look like so
so there's like um just a bit more
context guys sorry there's like 12 pods
back to back on the line so the guys
will be on one side the girls yeah on
another side and so let's say guy a goes
in one pod and girl a goes into another
pod opposite each other they're only
speaking through a thin wall yeah that's
how they communicate
they can hear each other but they can
never see each other yeah continue and
um
yeah so anyway sal was building a
relationship with mao and she wanted to
get a bit sexual with it
because she um she was talking she was
basically tossed out she was stuck
between two guys sailors uh jared
and sal spoiler anyone by the way i'm
about to give spoilers okay i have to
i'm i'm i'm not fast yeah i'm going to
watch you guys please man complain yes
spoiler alert it's there flashing
spoilers flashing spoilers
anyway
um sal and mao well we're good but
mallory and jared had a bit of sexy chat
this is like a good few days in so then
she's tossing between jared and
yeah yeah um tossing toss and tossing
but her and jared had a bit of sexy chat
okay and then you can tell she's
thinking [ __ ] so her next date was sal
she tried it and thought let me get sexy
with it okay
so they're talking talking fam i'm not
gonna lie to you it wasn't going well
she tried the sex chat on here she was
trying to sexy chat on him he was and he
was he was trying his best but he was
like oh
he was just being bad corny with it just
oh
oh okay yeah i like that whereas jared
was on it
man because he's a big black guy
a massive black guy and he's got a deep
voice yeah he's just seizures and he was
just saying like yeah
yeah what about this he was pursuing
this okay
mal's down for it so she's thinking [ __ ]
yeah yeah now i know where i'm at
sexually with jared let me find out
where i'm at especially with um
sal yeah so she's talking to sal about
what's this and all that and this and
he's like oh
oh okay and you can tell he's not really
he's just being mad bear passive and
he's like yeah i like this chat
and then
he's not giving him much backbone and
then
and then she was talked about tattoos
okay
and man said oh
um she's like oh he said something about
that was like have you got any tattoos
she was like yeah i've got one but um
i've got one on my body a man said
deepest voice i've heard might say
out of the blue donde
like animating them she quivered
she quivered
man kept it cool because his voice is
very monotone yeah but in a confident
way okay that he doesn't really get
apart from when that's the only like
dodgy bit was when
because he's very very very just like
yeah cool calm collected yeah yeah um
until she's trying the sexy chat that's
when he was like oh
and you're thinking who the [ __ ] is this
guy like you were this mister yeah cool
yeah and that's what she liked about you
until she's actually trying to get horny
with it and just acting a bit [ __ ] like
and then and then that's when he must
have realized like i need to step my
dick up and she was talking about
tattoos oh yeah i've got a tattoo
somewhere on my body and i said donde
i was like holy [ __ ] gang it changed the
mood like that gang gang but anyway
so i'll get back to that yeah that love
triangle i'll get back to that
so
you've got that there's i've got a few
favorite characters i just want to shine
some love on my favorite characters yeah
i haven't even finished the season yet i
don't know where it's going to go
i don't know where it's going to go i
haven't finished it yet like 10x or
something uh something like that and i
would have finished it last night but i
knew i wanted to talk to you about today
yeah yeah yeah but i would have put on
last night now i'm not going to yeah
yeah
there's a few
so one of my favorite uh favorite
characters guy called shake
hilarious he's the asian brother um
indian guy and he he gives me
mad aziz ansari vibes really he reminds
me so much of his ears and sorry
mannerisms mannerisms looks like
everything yeah he doesn't look exactly
like him okay but when you see like
certain like close-ups of his face like
[ __ ] he even look like he looks like him
okay he just
his voice sounds similar okay anyway guy
could shake bro he can't
pun not intended he can't shake the fact
that he needs to know what [ __ ] looks
like
he has to okay and then on the wrong
side fam he was in there one time and
he's trying
he's like yeah yeah yeah i loved it he's
doing prying questions like yeah yeah
yeah i love to work out
um
do you like to work out
and then
one chick was like no
it was like cool so what if we went for
a run like would you be running she was
like i don't like to sweat like i would
never be running you could and she was a
big girl as well and he was like i'm
safe
i know where this is going yeah and then
there's one thing he's talking to
and then they were getting into it yeah
and he's like he works as a dj he works
as something i think he's a dentist but
he also does like djing okay and he's
like yeah yeah like i just love to be at
like a festival and like good advice she
was like yeah yeah yeah festival sounds
good
and then um it was he was like yeah so
like
um what if like we're at a festival like
would you want to get on my shoulders
and stuff and then she was like yeah
yeah yeah i mean like if you she made a
joke like oh if you can carry me like
i'll get a i'll get your shoulders and
you can see he's like my ticket and he
was like
could i carry yeah
he's like if i went to carry you could
could i carry you would it be easy for
me to carry you oh
fam she looked the whole thing she was
like you're being [ __ ] disrespectful
right now and he's like nah my bad she
was like this is a show about intimacy
but um
anyways so he had a relationship she's
an indian girl as well okay
the one the other one he offended was
the indian guard as well and they both
admit that they've only ever been with
white people they've never been with
indian people okay but you can tell us
the first time they've actually had a
connection with another indian person
okay in a romantic way and you can tell
just like their upbringings are so
similar they're like
ra i've been missing out you can tell
they're both thinking [ __ ] i've been
missing out
i'm not dating within my race kind of
thing um because it's just easy and we
understand the same jokes
and uh
so one day he fam he realized that like
he's been he's [ __ ] up with this um
with oh [ __ ]
bad production i've got my light just in
the shot like that oh mad terrible
production
anyway
so um he realized it's like bro i've
just been
[ __ ] up
um
with this whole like not getting on
board of not knowing what people look
like and all these things
fam
so
he proposed to her he was i've got
connection with this woman
i'm tired of just being concerned of uh
like physical stuff and all that that
like i'm ready to commit like let's go
will you marry me she said yes gang
she's down for him okay found
so once that happens they meet i don't
know how to do that i mean obviously
yeah they go on they go on a honeymoon
thing so they went to mexico honeymoon
fam she's lips and she's down but they
they agree they're not gonna have sex
until the wedding fam all this all this
all this
bro
they and then they had the link up so
they finally meet some of the other
girls and all these things yes yes yes
sam he pulled one of the voice to the
side and then uh they were like oh how's
it going because some of these couples
have been [ __ ] yeah somebody's going
to be [ __ ] rags and he hasn't
obviously done it and he pulled one of
those boys inside his and they're like
how's it going and he said fam
i do not find her attractive
i said it man to man
i am not sexually attracted to her
i am not sexually attracted so man's
been lips and just cause just cause bro
yo
just to make her not feel bad yeah he
said the connection we have is mad but
fam when i look at her
i'm not attracted to it he wants a pen
pal he wants a
family a long distance phone call thing
but the singer's fam is dread because if
you see she's not bar fam oh she's she's
a lovely person she's not buff okay
she's not buffing okay okay okay so he's
effects i don't know where it's going to
go so i'm still waiting
but anyway so that couple
i'm intriguing because i need to know
when this is going yeah yeah yeah and um
who else oh fam
i'm waiting for this one
there is
oh there's a guy on there yeah you have
to watch it even at this point you have
to watch i'm gonna watch it though there
was a thing so there's a guy called
shane okay he's annoying okay he's
annoyed he's too energetic and he's has
a weird inferiority complex he needs
compliments all the time oh really and
he leans on the fact that i asked my
love language like a live positive
affirmations and all these things but
fam
he needs it too much that it's beyond a
love language he needs it he's desperate
for compliments if you don't compliment
him once per conversation he's livid oh
man he's so needy right that is a huge
inferior complex but
so he had a thing with two goals as well
okay
so there's shane
and then he had a deep connection with a
girl called natalie okay they were
getting a long fam they were connecting
um but she's not but it was purely it
wasn't very sexual
[Music]
purely just like
uh their ambitions and their like
uh insecurities and all these things
like they had a real good connection
then he had another connection with a
girl called shayna
shayna's banging
and she likes to [ __ ] oh say less
oh
less shayna likes to [ __ ] say less and
then so she would have mad flight it
comes out and she'd she digs shane
she's down shane shayna it's a shame and
shayna
okay she's down for shane okay so fam
every time they get in a pod together
it got sexual immediately
i like that i like you know how you're
sexual there's a headache
there's attention it's like bread and
butter for them i love [ __ ] so let me
paint a picture of shayna she's a
blunting okay
obviously
bang your face
titties and she loves like casual
loungewear crop top and joggers that's
her forte
it works perfect for her it works i can
see it if i'm should come in just like
joggers uh nice crop top and maybe like
a oversized shirt like a boy shirt yeah
buff she's buffy had i see it and then
um
he'd always get in there every time he
clocks it's her he'll get in there giddy
and the first thing he'll sit on the
floor take his jacket off sit on the
floor and blow what are you wearing over
there and then she'll give him details
and he'll be like [ __ ] him he's just
sitting there [ __ ] [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
hot
and [ __ ] like stop stop sorry i'm sure
their man had tension who had i'm
surprised he didn't just like bash one
out when he was in there i'm surprised i
didn't try and break through the ting oh
he said you're making me want to run
through a wall
you're making me want to run through a
[ __ ] wall wow
you want to bang her what i bet i
[ __ ] want to bang her fam and then
fam oh god
so he's had he's got this connection
and he's telling natalie you're my
favorite like i've written your name on
front of my notebook like i'm a kid like
you're natalie i'm down for you i love
you like this connection is next
but you can tell shane is this dirty
little secret yeah when he gets a date
with shayna yeah what the [ __ ] are you
wearing like this i want to do that so i
want to do this to you yeah and then um
one day gets in the pod and obviously
like you know when you're getting up you
don't know who you're talking to until
they announce themselves of course so he
gets in the pod and he's like hi he
walks in there doesn't know who's in
there he's like hi
she goes hi and he's like oh shayna what
are you wearing in there
silence shayna shane i've been waiting
for this all day what are you wearing in
there come talk to me why are you being
shy what's going on what are you wearing
in there
fam he's [ __ ] up she goes big man it's
natalie he's [ __ ] up
he's [ __ ]
man thought with his [ __ ] and not his
head he he had a heart dick he didn't
know what day it was mad
yeah soon she said
fam it's natalie
he said
[ __ ]
bro
there's nothing else you can say he said
[ __ ] there's nothing else you can say
and bro he gave
the most
toxic experience to the world that day
really
bro
he got so defensive it was wild really
it was wild how can you defend that
you've you've been baited out you [ __ ]
up bro
he came with the whole we're on this
show to meet people you know what it is
you've been talking to other people
she's a big man you told me you love me
you told me you my name was on the ting
why are you why are you trying this out
why are you flipping scripts now
and he's like big man like i don't know
why you're doing this to me
like i love you like all this [ __ ]
you're putting pressure on me like [ __ ]
this
fam he was getting angry in there
and i'm i was like wrong
wow he showed his true colors that day
when you put him on the spot he don't
like it bro yeah yeah he's gonna throw
anyone out of the baby in a corner you
can't put him in a corner yeah he'll
lash the [ __ ] out and make it seem like
it's your fault it was crazy to see but
anyway
out of his guilt
he was so livid he went back to his room
he was thinking i want to leave this
whole show i don't want to be here
anymore yeah yeah yeah vam went back
into his room
and you could tell because he was riled
up with so much guilt yeah
next time he was in the room
said marry me
next time he got in a room he was so
scared to lose her
he [ __ ] up so bad and he had so much
guilt next time he don't need to [ __ ]
marry me marry me
she is a [ __ ] she said yes
so now they're they're engaged and
they're they're off swanning off in
honeymoon so shane is none the wiser fam
shayna he shayna found out because
obviously when they come into the
community
oh my god
shayna's face dropped
shayna's face dropped but he didn't talk
to shayna for like two three days but
post that or pre that i can't remember
the timeline probably but basically i
think pre that
pre that once he got clocked he didn't
talk to shane for a couple days but
shayna was also i said no that's
it that's it that's it sorry i'm mixing
up timelines so he [ __ ] up okay then
the next time he said be my girlfriend
to natalie i want you to be my
girlfriend the next time you saw shayna
shannon's like
big man why am i hearing you've got a
girlfriend
and then again defensive again defensive
again
defensive again true colors again and
then
but the thing is the only point he had
with shayna is that
she yes she was down for the sexy chat
but she was never really she's all
playing it's all play play for her she
never really said like i really like you
like i actually she was never really
like forthcoming with her feelings she
was down for the sex chat but any
anything deep she wasn't about with him
she would tell camera like i'm i'm
feeling it but she would never tell him
okay okay okay um so
she had a deep connection with him so
once he um so
after this whole girlfriend chat he
didn't chat for her for like two three
days okay in his mind it's done
so he was just focused on natalie then
he proposed to natalie and then at least
said yes she's come in and then she's
only so shane is now thinking [ __ ] off
shane yeah so she had another connection
with another guy called ryan okay so she
put all her effort into ryan
ryan
after ryan's a psychopath
listen to me bro i'm hearing you brother
let me sit up listen yes ryan's a psycho
yeah what's he saying bro he's a
delusion
yeah yeah he lives in a constant state
of delusion
yeah yeah he's crazy bro so basically
shayna so now we're with shayna and ryan
yes shayna's very um
shayna's very religious even though
she's down for this [ __ ] chat yeah yeah
super christian yeah and it's important
for her to like raise her kids christian
and go to church every sunday and all
that stuff she's she's just once
dick
yeah but behind closed door she wants to
get [ __ ]
[Music]
so
anyway she's now put her effort into
ryan yeah ryan's a hardcore atheist okay
so they finally get randomly get into
the comments of conversation of religion
okay and then he's like i'm an atheist
she's like i'm a christian he makes a
couple bad jokes about christianity and
like brainwashing all these things
things turn a bit sour okay so
she's vex about losing shane she's now
had an argument with her back up
ryan basically goes back he has a talk
with himself and he's like you know what
yeah like
i don't actually care if we have these
disagreements like i don't care if we
feel differently about religion religion
like i'm down for you bro like i'm down
for you so he hop skips and jumps
next day marry me
marry me
and she's so heartbreaking heartbroken
about shane she says [ __ ] it let's go
then immediately her head's swinging um
she's thinking in me fam when i say
immediately i'm saying as soon as she
left the pod
she's on the interesting fam i don't
know i don't know i don't know but the
thing is she's only leaning on this
religion thing that's the thing she's
saying this religion thing are our
differences she kept saying our
difference is our differences
really she's just not feeling him
so after she's agreed to marry my man
shane
goes in to see uh natalie
and he's like i've been thinking about
you all day
it's shayna
she says shane is shayna
i said what the [ __ ]
she's like bro i just she's already
agreed to marry ryan yeah bro i need to
tell you i'm so sorry i was playing all
this coiting but fam like i've come to
realize like i know you're engaged i
know what it is fam
i [ __ ] love you
like i [ __ ] care about you bro i know
i wasn't willing to tell you before
because i have like issues with about
commitment or rejection all these things
but i [ __ ] love you bro
man said what are you doing
i was i was with shane on this one yeah
yeah why are you doing this to me yeah
yeah he was
when i say he was pacing up and down the
room
he was pacing up and down the room yeah
he didn't know what to do yeah
he said [ __ ] [ __ ] he was screaming in
there
shayna's in there crying he's like why
didn't you say this sooner yeah why
didn't you say i was down for you bro
why didn't you say this sooner she said
i'm sorry if i'm sorry like i'm just
sorry he said it's too late it's [ __ ]
too late and you could tell he was
thinking about calling off the whole
wedding yeah of course um of course he
said it's [ __ ] too late
so she's gone ahead said fine cool gone
ahead
met ryan now she's seen ryan now and you
can tell she's not
fam she was back in her dressing room
neck in shots
neck in it oh
so as soon as they've met
ryan's gassed he's freaking it man said
[ __ ] hell you're banging
he finally got a hand and made her talk
he's like yeah he said
he can't believe how lucky he is
she said to him on the spot
straight away it's the first time
they've ever met fam she whispered to
him she literally pulled him and said
bro
disengagement i don't think it's gonna
work
after you don't do the spin yeah fam
this he everyone else in this situation
is nothing but gas to meet one another
fam she said i don't think this is gonna
work he said what
she's like bro our difference is this
and that like i'm stressed like i've
been engaged before it really didn't
work out like i i'm not trying to make
mistakes and i have to go how i feel
like i don't think it's gonna work
this want to take he's a [ __ ]
psychopath fam it went in one ear out
the other
he said fam we're just gonna have to try
what does that even mean brother i'm
just gonna have to try it like say
there's a gun to both of our heads we're
just gonna have to try i'm willing to
try if you're willing to try we're
trying to tell you you said but
basically we're trying
so they went into mexico
bro first night in mexico she said i
think we should sleep in separate beds
separate rooms
i said what
fam
whilst they're asleep
she said cool i think we should sleep in
separate rooms i just don't want us to
get too physical like yeah it's still
early days and everything like that
and i said all right to be fair i
respect you i want to respect your
boundaries all these things um like
obviously you just met me i can stand
like i can tell you now to your face
like i wouldn't try a ting like i
wouldn't try and [ __ ] you but i can
understand that you're still not
comfortable if you want to sleep in your
own room she said bear thank you for
understanding she said fam she gave him
a kiss good night and i said what you're
going in the room now she said yeah yeah
it's late
he looked at the time it was
704. pm 704 he's up pips it's seven
o'clock
she was like
oh
anyway she still went bless
fam while she's in there
she packed her bags and left
she packed her bags and left mexico
mad fam madisting she's not about it so
now
she first time they met she said she's
not down so she didn't even get to meet
the other brother no she didn't shane
she didn't meet shane
lucky for shane that they didn't meet
that's what i said i haven't finished
the season yet i don't know if they're
gonna i don't know if she's gonna come
back and they'll meet because she i'm
telling you bro shane don't want to meet
her because natalie bless her lovely
girl not banging
shayna is
banging
so
so bro um
so so she's left
this one i said again psychopath yeah he
goes into interviewing and says
obviously i'm glad she left but
i'm certain she's going to come back
we're going to be alright she just needs
some time to herself we're going to be
fine we're going to be fine she's left
you yeah she's literally left you in
mexico
it's not gonna be all right
she's gone yeah she didn't even say bye
yeah the producer had to tell you she
was gone 704 i'm going to go to my own
room yeah
he's delusional wow he saw titties and
just can't think straight in
he's thinking in his head i'm i'm never
going to get better than this it has to
work yeah [ __ ]
so
there's that um so all going through
their paces
and then
um the next yeah the love triangle now
let's get back to the love triangle
and jaret
so
jarrah so as mao's got a connection
with so sal only likes mao yes
mao
mm-hmm like so sal only likes mao sal is
donde yeah
mao likes him yeah but she also likes
jarrah yeah jared likes mao yeah but
also likes another thing i can't
remember her name right now say less
she's just on outside yeah yeah yeah say
less so he likes two yeah she likes to
say less
salary likes her and next thing only
likes jaret okay
okay it's one of them one of them ones
so in the interview things mallory's
saying i [ __ ] i'm feeling jarrett
mallory i'm feeling jared but i'm also
[ __ ] feeling sal i don't know who i
like more
jarrett in the interview i'm feeling the
the random i can't remember
but i'm um
feeling mallory as well i don't know
he's saying i don't know which is which
one day i go in there i'm feeling my
goal next day malory i'm back and forth
all the time and i'm only saying the
same thing i'm back and forth for the
time
so then one day fam he parks up the
courage and says i'm [ __ ] he says we
don't know who i'm going to propose
tomorrow
i'm proposing tomorrow if he goes in the
room we still don't know mallory's in
there
and he says let me ask you a question
hypothetically if i was to propose to
you would you say yes
that's a bit of a loaded question fam
it's proposing without actually
proposing it's loaded that's loaded but
when i say if i'm there in the brink
yeah and when they're from they've been
talking about kids they've been talking
about this they've been talking talking
he's not it's not a leap for him okay
they've been talking bro and the
conversation they were having was about
this kind of thing like living together
all these things okay so he said bro to
be fair let me ask you if i was to
propose what would you say
fam
she started barling she's balling
she said fam
i'm feeling you but i'm feeling someone
else a bit more
i'd have to say no
[Music]
yo
bro yeah i'll have to say no have to say
no she's crying now oh she knows he's
done yeah he's yeah yeah hypothetical or
not yeah it's not okay he started
balling through that he's balling his
eyes out now nah this is jared right
jairus but big black guy barling no he's
not he's balling bro
he's balling
he's lost mallory okay so then
mallory now has no choice but to be with
saul but that's who she really wants to
be yeah wants to be with her he proposes
she says yes gang gang yeah jarrett now
has a fallback
who in his defense he is feeling very
much but
his thing
now knows that he proposed to mao
hypothetically hypothetically okay so
now she knows he's not his fur she's not
his first choice so
then me
so now he has to go in there with his
towel between his legs
about look i'm not gonna lie to you
i put my first foot forward with mal she
rejected me but i can't pretend
like i i'm not feeling you just as much
so i'm gonna have to shoot my shop
regardless
because i'm not leaving here with
nothing yeah i need to leave with a with
a wife long story short that's what the
rules say
yeah
so i'm not losing this connection with
you just because i i took a shot with
mao yeah yeah and then fam she was vex
at him cussed him out but eventually she
came around now they're engaged
but them two met in mexico
um jared and jared and
mal met in mexico fam
connection in there wow drinks were
drinking yeah fam
i saw a dark side to jarrett
it shows you what a man will do when he
wants a woman so he's happy with his
thing that he's got and mal's happy with
sal but she said already my type is big
black guys that's basically what she
said big bad guys that i've been to
sport they're into this and they had a
connection sal is not what he goes for
and mao's banging as well she's banging
as well so as soon as he saw her you
could get [ __ ]
she's thick as well
[Music]
yeah
and the thing that is chosen is like
short and thin okay so love is she's
pretty she's nice but you can tell he
looks at mourinho
yeah yeah lunch yeah yeah yeah
bento box
you pack lunch
[Music]
so fam they're getting there and then
they're tipsy they're avoided they're so
awkward they're avoiding in tougher the
whole time until they've been drinking
drinking and they run he runs up and
then says like well go on i'm sorry
and they're like his course calls call
fam and then they're talking she's
trying to say
she basically says like
you're the one still like you're it
i'm not going anywhere so i was my guy
but
yeah like your ticket boxes found and
he's telling them you're ticking boxes
as well
they've got tension bro
i can imagine i can imagine
i can imagine [ __ ] yeah fam
yes
um and then so that's also so what where
i'm at right now we've got shaken his
ting and he you can pay him to [ __ ] her
yeah yeah yeah
they're two asians right yeah they're
the two agents couldn't pay attention to
man i'm not feeling huh
he said it's like three
you've got shane and natalie yeah
shayna's gone yeah i'm waiting for her
to come back so shane can meet her
because he's going to want her yeah
he's going to want her yeah
he's going to be so live and he can't
hide his emotions yeah he's so
expressive as you say as soon as he sees
her you can say it's gonna be like [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ]
um
and she's feeling him so much that
she'll risk her life to move to him
again
she loves him wow so there's that then
there's um obviously jared and his thing
and then sal and mao yeah and then
there's one more couple
i can't remember i think oh i can't
remember their name i can't remember eat
no i think the girls called danielle the
other guys called like craig or
something i can't remember his name
daniel's a crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
just an fyi fyi she's [ __ ]
crazy okay
give it a footnote fam i'll just give
you an example so basically she used to
be fat okay she lost bare weight okay
and now she's still insecure she assumes
everyone thinks she's hideous okay um
and i like she just assumes her man will
leave her at any given opportunity oh
wow that is a
her head is a dark place wow found one
day so the day that they had the drink
up she had food poisoning so she had to
stay home and he told her to her face
like i don't have to go like i'll stay
with you like i smile into me i don't
even care like i'll stay with you she
said no no no go you need to meet
everyone go go go go go so he went
comes back from she's livid
she's living at him and he's like what
was going on she was like i was here by
myself for three hours i didn't know
what you were doing
i said what
you told me i told you i'll stay yeah
you told me to go she was like how would
you like it if you were in the in the
[ __ ] bathroom for three hours crying
he said you were crying she was i was in
the in the wardrobe was like crying for
three hours
and then and she finally she is when you
were coming back he's like i came
straight back she's like you didn't come
straight back i saw you talking to like
the concierge or some [ __ ] he was like i
was talking to her about the climate she
was like i don't care what you were
talking about
like you don't understand the [ __ ] goes
through my head fam wow she's insecure
man
man said i'm done
he said i'm done
i don't need she tried to walk out the
door she dragged her back and she said
please please don't that he said get off
me i'm i'm done
you're you're nuts fam
you're [ __ ] crazy
what are you even on about no so they
eventually squashed it the next morning
it's like nothing ever happened and i
was thinking bro that's a red red flag
bro get out wow so anyway yeah that's
what's that's the circle i'm in the
minute i'm gonna finish the whole thing
tonight that's something that's juicy
show juicy it's juicy bro
it's juicy
shane
fought natalie with shayna and you came
in for a quick [ __ ] chat
oh
i was sat on the sofa i crawled onto the
floor
in front of the tv
i was peeled here no it was too saucy no
when he [ __ ] up from he said [ __ ]
that's hilarious
funnier [ __ ] oh gang i can't say yeah
obviously i've spoiled everything
i've got to watch the whole ticket it's
just i'm still going to feel the same
way i felt as you said it to me because
i don't know what any of them look like
yeah exactly so it might have imagined
everything yeah yeah i've imagined
everything yeah yeah bro i'm going to
feel the same way
i thought i'd hate it
it's banging is that the first loveliest
brand you've ever seen yeah i didn't see
season one okay what made you watch
season two just because people kept
messaging me okay people just kept
messing and saying watch you watch your
watch i was like all right [ __ ] it man
i'm gonna watch it okay um oh [ __ ] it's
good
say less i love when i feel a little bit
of trash tv mm-hmm a juicy bit of trash
tv i love it same same thing um
yeah man um
on that note we're bringing back the x
no we are indeed brother yeah so in
celebration of the new merch launch for
the first time in a few months we're
going to bring back the x so i've done a
deep dive on uh the tick tock comments
okay and we're uh we're bringing back a
few examples let me set up just for a
laugh you lost let me set up for this
we've not done this in a minute we
haven't our what the ick special yeah
yeah yeah
first one
when he walks downhill and his feet slap
the floor
bro
we did that today today
today i'm glad you thought that we did
that today so i was thinking that when
we were walking down to the shops today
avoidable
it's gravitational pull cuz
whose fault is that mine or gods
bro the front your heel connects and it
just slaps
there's nothing you can do gravitational
pull there's nothing you can't do man oh
cold
i'm not cold-hearted oh my days that was
sweet in me
i don't know why
there's a few on here that are literally
you
so you're going to have to raise your
hand twice or thrice
this one
when their nose breathing and it makes
that whistle sound
in a quiet room
it's if you're it's infuriating
embarrassing i don't even know oh it's
it's just so annoying brother
it's so annoying
blow your nose it's unfair but the thing
is i can't
i [ __ ] can't
it's not my fault bro i know i didn't
choose this life oh it's so [ __ ] man
yeah your sinuses are
are blocked sam i need sun i need sun i
need it quick bro
when he puts his hand under the
automatic sanitizer and nothing comes
out
[Laughter]
bro i've had it about five times
when i put my hand on there and it goes
nothing comes up
and you have to look around you like
you give yourself the question
and i walk my dry hands on my seat it's
so embarrassing
oh it's annoying bro the worst is when
it gives you too much
i i got to a point i just i just dash it
on the floor
it gave me a massive squelch and just
dashed it on the floor
[Laughter]
so [ __ ] annoying bro
so um oh when he uses his passport as id
bro no brother yes yes no but yes when
you use your password
get a license fam oh man professional
professional just apply
just apply
passport as a as id
is so dangerous and such a rookie move
as well oh it's butters bro it is buzz
it's butters bro passport as id is
butter fair play i can imagine i can
imagine because it doesn't even fit
comfortably in the pocket it doesn't
you're walking around with some squares
here or it's a back pocket
no man no no no no harrison man
fam when his windscreen won't defrost
and he has to look through the little
circle
it's the story of my life dangerous game
it is it's a dangerous way when i used
to commute to work i didn't have a
minute to spare
i
[Music]
i didn't have a minute to spare bro
i was driving my 2013 astra yeah i
didn't have time
so i found that little hole was all i
had i just and you're there hitch up on
the thing yeah yeah oh
it's so infuriating you have a minute to
spare fam it's whole and and winter yeah
yeah yeah [ __ ] it
that's hilarious i hated my life um oh
when it takes him more than once to
enter a roundabout
that's tough
that stuff that just shows the lack of
confidence a man has when it comes to
pressure yeah yeah
ah and there's there's a queue behind it
there's a queue behind him when there's
when you find that spot and you're like
gang and then you misjudge it or you
take a half a second too long you lose
it you slam on the brakes and a caught
wobbles and then max next man baby baby
you're sweating your heart's racing
you're looking left and right i can
never have a female in the passenger she
would take her hand off you
i've had i'd rather risk my life
i'd rather risk my life i'm not pressing
that break
i swear you've got to show the dangerous
side oh yeah you've got to show the
dangerous side i'm about to take it to
the limit yeah that's hilarious i could
kill us at any second suck me now
that's the life she needs to know she's
just she's entered yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
thank god i've never experienced this if
i ever do
kill me
when you let him drive and he doesn't
need to move the seat back
wow
the thing is before you said that i
didn't know where you were going to go
with you yeah yeah family
drive he doesn't even need to move the
seat back wow
i've never experienced that and i never
will touch wood oh hundred percent
wow 100
wow
embarrassing
and you might just get in the seat
comfortably
everything's positioned yeah just wow
he doesn't need to move the seat back
that's humiliating wow women are
specific because it turns into a ich
when she gets back in
because when you i don't know bro like
when you get in mm-hmm
you want her to sit in there i think
[ __ ] hell [ __ ] now giant's been
here
so i mean she's looking she's reaching
the steering wheel like this she can't
even reach the [ __ ] yeah she can't touch
the pedals she's right [ __ ] who's been
in here
that's a giant
hilarious yeah fam yao ming's been up in
my bed man yeah that's what you wanted
to feel like
yeah but nah oh that's embarrassing wow
say less um
oh dear
when he forgets his bottle and has to
drink from the water fountain no no no
no no no no no no no no no no run
i would go out go shop and get myself a
bowl water fountain
bro no brother when you when you were
bearded like us as well and it's
slurping next government water
slurping boris's water and coming back
and having the residue sprinkled in my
baby glistening just here the strap you
bit you yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that you [ __ ]
you might as well suck boris off
that's what you're doing that's what
you're telling me yeah your bet you're
arching your back and you're slurping
next man's water
from the faucet
you [ __ ] yo
oh it's too embarrassing i haven't
touched a water fountain since i was a
kid oh my [ __ ] water and even then i
hated it
nah
you don't know what next man's tongue's
been doing bruv you know what yeah you
know when you're in school and and then
for some reason the pressure pressure is
just and this goes straight down and
then you look at it and you think [ __ ]
and you have to get deep
oh oh it makes me sick thinking about it
it makes me sick thinking about it bro
it's not fair
because you know next man has put his
mouth all over now he's sucked the whole
time all over that because he's parched
he's been running around for 15 he's
part yeah fam oh the playground had him
up yeah man and he don't give off he
doesn't give a [ __ ] i can i can picture
the ute now he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
doesn't even [ __ ] about you or anything
oh [ __ ] sake oh that's hilarious oh
bro this one
this is one but
what i said you might have to raise your
hands twice
when he's really i can't say it
can't say it
when he's really thirsty and you can
hear him breathing in the glass
from
oh my god funny we were just talking
about purchase or i've been parched in
my day brother oh
there are times where i just gulp the
water bro
when i was a kid and i've been out with
my boys yeah and i run into the yard
just to get uh
to get a glass of fruit and barley
summer fruits
find you like
when you take a break you don't even put
the gl your brakes here yeah
all you do is
and then you continue you don't let the
glass move because all you do is close
your mouth
and you let the water sit on your lips
because you have to finish this whole
glass that's so embarrassing
that's so embarrassing
um oh when his parents tell him off no
when his parents tell him to stop
shoving off yo
embarrassing
embarrassing for everyone
embarrassing for everyone wow
every parent has says this wow and every
child doesn't want to commit murder for
it every parent has said it and every
child is willing to risk it all right to
make it stop
stop showing off wow stop showing off
freddie a little friend yeah stop
showing up in front of your little boys
[ __ ] you
exactly exactly you just look at him why
mom
why [ __ ] you
do you know you done to me my dude stop
showing off in front of your friends
bullied that
a universal sentence yeah yeah yeah yeah
every mom has said that yeah stop
showing off oh your mom's showing up
um that's hilarious all right last one
this one sweeted me kept hit me when he
tries to blow up a balloon but can't get
past the initial barrier
initial barrier best description i've
ever heard ever the initial barrier you
get that
and then it's you it's your lungs versus
the balloon it's you or the balloon and
you go
oh and you get it good
[Laughter]
and you see the ting steve yeah you're
happy bro
the logs want to collapse after the
first breath the initial barrier
that's a thick balloon that's a thick
balloon that's what she said but
um yeah bro that's the best description
of anything i've ever heard the initial
barrier well i can't get past the
initial barrier women are cutthroat bro
nail on head all the time if you can't
get back it
you're drinking your own air yeah it's
going to clap back at you
and you're going to be perplexed yeah
yeah you've got nothing left in the tank
literally me that's hilarious but yeah
um thank you for that
oh that was funny jesus christ nice to
bring back the x uh so guys as always
head on over to patreon.com for us our
shits and gigs
um catch us over there on thursday three
pound a month tempe a day
this week only guys the what the ick
merch is on the shelves
um it's going to be going hot and fast
so get as much as you can links in the
description guys we look forward to
seeing it in um
on your breasts really and um as always
guys
thank you for watching thank you for
listening love love love gang all right
bless
[Music]